Two more
sentences are being
handed down today
for members of the Oath Keepers,
a far
right extremist group
for their role
in the January six Capitol attack.
One of them is Army veteran
Jessica Watkins.
She was just sentenced to eight
and a half years in prison.
Sentencing for the other member.
Kenneth Harrelson is happening
this very hour.
This all comes one day
after the group's founder,
Stuart Rhodes, was hit
with the most severe sentence
yet tied to the Capitol insurrection
with a judge
describing him
as an ongoing threat to democracy.
The unrepentant Rhodes
was sentenced to 18 years in prison.
CNN's Evan Perez is covering this for us.
We also have former federal prosecutors
who to break down
the legal aspects of this.
Evan, starting with you.
How does this Watkins sentence measure up
with what prosecutors were calling for?
Well,
the prosecutors were asking for 18 years.
And but it's very clear that
certainly the judge believed that
Jessica Watkins
told the story that, you know,
certainly
maybe got a little bit of empathy
from the judge
because of the fact that, you know,
she's struggled through a lot
she identifies as a transgender
person and
served in the military,
described how difficult that was for her.
And really
at least in the end finally said that
that she believed
she now realizes
what happened
that day was wrong
and that she should be punished
and was willing
to accept that punishment.
The prosecutors were not buying it.
They're citing some of her communications
even from jail, where she was making
fun of the police officers saying,
boo hoo,
and saying that they incited the riot
by attacking innocent protesters.
Of course, that's not what happened.
So, you know, the judge
the judge, though,
did recognize again
that this is a person
who has gone through a lot and
and really called out,
call out,
called out her her conduct and said,
you know, this is
this is somebody who
went through all of this
all of this personal struggle
and should have shown more
empathy to the people
who are working in the capital that day.
And yet again,
Stewart Rhodes,
the ringleader of the Oath Keepers,
he got 18 years.
Prosecutors wanted 25.
He didn't actually enter the capital
on that day.
And that's part of the argument
that his lawyers were making.
These other two
that are being sentenced today,
including Jessica Watkins.
She did enter the capital. Right.
And I think this judge made a
is really showing himself
to be
a very discerning
and compassionate judge.
I think, you know,
the federal judges often
don't have as much experience
sentencing people
who have committed violent crimes
and he's really taking a careful
look at these circumstances
to distinguish.
Now, I was a little bit surprised.
I thought Rhodes
and this was a little bit late,
given that the prosecutors
were asking for the 25 years
and given his very stern rebuke
to Rhodes, saying, you're still a danger.
And so
a lot of times with violent criminals,
part of the point of a long sentence
is having them age out
so they're less violent
when they get out.
But with Rhodes, he's really a leader.
It's not that he's personally violent.
He's inspiring, he's talking and such.
And that's the danger.
And I think the judge
of probably appropriately
is recognizing the distinction
between that kind of a leader,
mastermind of these things
versus the people who are still more
the foot soldiers and varying degrees.
But it's
clear, though,
like, you know,
the judge points out
that Watkins was not just a foot soldier.
She was definitely a leader of this Ohio
group of Oath Keepers.
And, you know,
she was using encrypted communications.
She was giving instructions
on how to get rid of evidence.
Again, very proud of what she was doing.
That day.
Perhaps now she realizes what she did.
And Shane,
you mentioned that part of
the judge's intent is to keep
these folks behind bars for long enough.
So that they're not threats
when they come out.
Part of
it also has to do with deterrence.
Right. Right.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I think
probably for the deterrence,
hopefully some people who are
kind of taken up with this kind of notion
and thinking
they're seeing this and realizing it's
not just like a cosplay fantasy
that they can do these things.
There's no accountability for it.
And that is certainly
one of the important points here
is that
even though this charge
has been used very often,
we haven't seen this, thankfully.
Very often
it's sending a message out
that this is real.
People take this seriously
people were hurt.
Yeah.
I mean, look,
but one of the things that I think
is denting that
the whole idea of trying
to prevent other people from doing
this is the fact that you have
a presidential candidates
who are out there saying publicly
that they're planning to
to pardon some of these people
because they don't view
January six in the same way.
And how do you take that message
that former President Trump
is speaking of people
like Stewart
Rhodes as if they're political prisoners,
as if he's some kind of martyr?
Yeah, I think that's very damaging
to the country.
It does hurt
the sort of disincentives to people
because the people most prone
to falling into this
are the very people that folks like
Trump is speaking to.
And that's definitely problematic.